así
anteriormente descubrimos que para tomar
una imagen muy brillante con nuestra
cámara estenopeica necesitábamos una
apertura grande pero cuando lo hicimos
la imagen resultante se veía borrosa
porque los rayos de luz de cada punto de
nuestra escena se dispersaban en una
área más grande del plano de la imagen
veamos un ejemplo los rayos de luz
llegan a la derecha y son casi paralelos
como si vinieran de un objeto que
estuviera muy lejos como el sol con una
apertura pequeña estos rayos sólo
iluminarán un puntito del plano de la
imagen
pero para que funcione una apertura
mayor necesitamos dirigir todos estos
rayos de luz hacia un puntito sin
descartar ni un solo rayo
necesitamos refractar los
que usamos cuando queremos refractar la
luz un objetivo o lente si añadimos una
lente a nuestra cámara hará que los
rayos de luz convergen así el punto
donde convergen estos rayos de luz se
conoce como punto focal resulta que la
forma o curvatura de la lente determina
que tanto se desvían los rayos de luz si
incrementamos la curvatura de la lente
los rayos se enfocan muy cerca de la
lente si reducimos la curvatura se
enfocan más lejos lo que queremos es
enfocar los rayos de luz exactamente
sobre el plano de la imagen eso nos dará
una imagen nítida para cada distancia
particular entre lente y plano de la
imagen hay un diseño de lente o
curvatura que enfocará los rayos de luz
sobre el plano de la imagen
llamamos distancia focal de la lente a
la distancia a la cual la lente enfoca
estos rayos paralelos
puedes tener una lente que enfoca cerca
de la apertura y obtendrás un campo de
visión más amplio se conoce como el
lente u objetivo gran angular por
ejemplo un objetivo de 28 milímetros
como el que estamos usando tiene una
distancia focal de 28 milímetros y
produce una imagen con un campo de
visión amplio puedes tener una lente que
enfoca la luz más allá de la apertura se
llama teleobjetivo por ejemplo una lente
de 120 milímetros como la que estamos
usando tiene una distancia focal de 120
milímetros capturaremos menos de la
escena así mientras que una lente de 50
milímetros como la que estamos usando
ahora nos da una perspectiva de
apariencia natural para cualquier tipo
de lente la película o el sensor de luz
necesita una cierta cantidad de luz para
registrar una imagen adecuadamente poca
luz y todo se ve oscuro mucha luz y todo
se ve blanco controlamos cuánta luz se
recibe ajustando el tamaño o el diámetro
de la apertura que también se mide en mm
otros algunas cámaras como esta te
permiten ajustar la apertura con este
anillo los números de este anillo son
pasos
efe que se definen como la razón de la
distancia focal de la lente sobre el
diámetro de la apertura si queremos una
apertura de 25 milímetros en una lente
de 50 milímetros pondremos el número f
en 2 porque 50 milímetros dividido entre
25 milímetros es igual a 2 por ejemplo
si ponemos el paso efe de una lente de
100 milímetros en dos conseguimos
la misma cantidad de luz que con una
lente de 50 milímetros con el paso efe
en 2 el paso efe está allí por una razón
importante detengámonos para que puedas
practicarlo en el ejercicio siguiente
que quede claro esa foto la tomé con
paso f en 2